close your eyes and let me take you back
to a simpler time dunkaroos were a high
value lunch snack Bagel Bites every day
after school and yes you burnt the roof
of your mouth every damn time you
dreamed of looking like the girl in a
Noxzema commercial you never left the
house without your sugar plum lip
smackers choker or butterfly Clips oh
me the butterfly Clips what a look
you use lemon juice or Kool-Aid to dye
your hair when your mom said no to the
legit dye alanis's ironic lived
rent-free in your head and the letters
jtt meant everything to you the 90s to
me is the ultimate in Nostalgia it's
where I spend my formative years as a
kid and preteen aka the days before life
got a little more dramatic and
complicated so today I'll be taking a
trip down memory lane and building a
balanced day of eats based around the
most iconic 90s films so grab your
favorite popcorn Mystic pizza or
meatball that's good meatball and come
along for the ride hey guys I'm Abby
sharp Elder Millennial and 90s kid
welcome to Abby's kitchen
foreign
[Music]
a quick disclaimer that the meals I'm
making in this video are not a
suggestion of how you should eat they're
simply what I made for myself on a
random day inspired by my favorite
nostalgic 90s movies where I try to
transform them into General balanced day
of eating Abby style also if you're new
here don't forget to subscribe to this
channel you are going to love the new
videos we are pumping out here and
follow me on Instagram and Tick Tock at
Abby's kitchen let me hop in here super
quick to type out today's sponsor Disney
Emoji blitz so I have two kids under
five we are big on Disney over here so
at my son's request I recently
downloaded Disney Emoji Blitz and it's
safe to say mama is loving this game
this is a match 3 game which allows you
to collect and play with hundreds of
different Disney Pixar and Star Wars
emojis from The Lion King Little Mermaid
zootopia Toy Story and more each Emoji
has its own unique power or and there's
actual strategy built into the game so
yeah even though my kids love watching
me play there's still kind of too young
to fully grasp it yet my favorite emoji
or maybe I should say E's favorite emoji
is of course buzz but we also love all
of the different rainbow characters
because let's be real we love anything
rainbow over here but it's super fun if
you have a collector's mentality because
there are new characters added every
single month in a variety of different
categories you can also earn emojis and
send them to your friends and right now
Disney Emoji Blitz is celebrating Disney
100 all year long so there's a new
Platinum Emoji to collect every month
and if you collect them all you also get
a special Platinum mini so if you want a
super fun Match 3 game that you and the
family will love you can download the
game for free using the link below on
your mobile device or your tablet and
you can get Mickey for free just for
downloading okay I would be lying if I
said I wasn't the mostest excited about
today's video because I feel like
Millennials are obsessed with the 90s
because it just brings back like our
most nostalgic feel-good moments but
looking back now I will be lying if I
said there wasn't a dark side this was
the birthplace of the whole heroin Chic
era a la Kate Moss which unfortunately
we are seeing a Resurgence of in the
media and fashion now in the 90s I was
between the ages of 3 and 13. so I was
mostly oblivious to a lot of dye culture
messaging but nowadays most pre-teens of
this age have social media accounts they
have their own phone they have non-stop
access to this messaging so I do think
that this rebirth is particularly
problematic it just feels like no one is
immune hmm
but this feels like a lot to unpack
before 9am we are going into some dark
dark places so let me finish my coffee
make breakfast and we'll pick it up a
little later on folks we must express
our gratitude to the high master and
when I say hi master I'm talking about
base
quantities hey Lego my Eggo
Eggo screen childhood to me I'm pretty
sure these solely sustained me from like
the age of three until 16. at least like
it was just straight up Eggos with
pancake syrup every day and I'm
not mad about it also leave me a comment
below but did anyone else only ever get
like Aunt Jemima's pancake syrup growing
up my parents never bought the real
maple syrup I didn't even know there was
a difference until I was like 30. okay
like maybe we should give myself a
little more credit but still and to all
the Almond moms out there
I survived all right while I get these
bad boys in the toaster Abby can you
like talk about the difference between
Maple and pancake syrup
you got it so maple syrup is pancake
syrup but pancake syrup isn't maple
syrup strike that reverse it okay let's
break it down so if we compare Aunt
jemimas with pure luxury Canadian Liquid
Gold they basically have the same amount
of calories and sugar around 200
calories and 50-ish grams of carbs the
difference is really in the ingredients
maple syrup is made from a labor
intestine process called sugaring where
maple trees are tapped in the winter and
table syrup is mainly made from corn
syrup and high fructose corn syrup plus
some additives and maple flavor as I
discussed in my scary food ingredients
video right here there's a lot of
conflicting evidence about high fructose
corn syrup in short the most common type
of high fructose corn syrup has a
similar fructose to glucose ratio as
table sugar and pretty close to honey
maple syrup is predominantly sucrose
which does make it have a lower glycemic
index and that arguably does give it a
slight metabolic and nutritional Edge
but despite the higher fructose ratio
and high fructose corn syrup when
compared to different amounts of sucrose
or table sugar there doesn't seem to be
much difference in insulin response
leptin levels fullness levels or weight
change I prefer maple syrup to table
syrup mainly because I find the flavor
and texture far superior which means I
ultimately feel satisfied on less but
hey if you love your pancake syrup
amazing you do you choose whatever
sweetener you like best and use it in
moderation
oh yeah that smell
s like my childhood now in the 90s for
me breakfast would have been maybe one
to two of these Eggos margarine because
we never had butter growing up and
pancake syrup pretty much that was it I
am not knocking that Mom you're doing a
good job you doing a good job
but today we're swapping out my
childhood fave
with maple syrup the real deal it is
just it just it's different right and we
gotta support local Canadian products
and to make this conehead approved we
either need an abnormal shaped head
Brody can you do that in editing or mass
quantities
[Music]
or we'll just make it a hunger crushing
combo so
a little peanut butter
you gotta get in every single hole I
really fell in love with all of them do
you guys remember when you're a kid and
the maple syrup if it was not in every
single compartment someone was having a
fit and that's where my OCD started only
one am I the only one maybe all right a
little bit
in all the crevices
because I mean these are delicious but
just not gonna fill your girl up oh
all right done
hemp hurts because
it's my little adult
touch
bloops or whatever other kind of fruit
you might have
and you know what we'll just throw a
little bit more on the side here for
some extra fiber fill her up look at
these massive grapes we're gonna add a
little more protein
got some full fat Greek yogurt
oh memory unlocked guys when my mom was
really just like not having it we got
for breakfast waffles with ice cream
yeah it was good it was good this is
gonna be good too all right little maple
syrup
oh yeah look at that
we have lots of fiber-rich carbs in our
berries here plus our nut butter and
hemp hearts protein and healthy fats in
the hemp hearts and nut butter and we've
got some extra protein in the Greek
yogurt there it looks like a huge
upgrade for my Aunt Jemima margarine
situation of my childhood but let's see
how it tastes is it worth me having to
redo my whole makeup in order to eat it
like a cone head
that's so good though okay this day
needs a little physical activity and for
this I'm thrown to my favorite 90s
character of all time
America
when I get nervous sometimes
I just put my fingers under my arms and
I smell it like this
ah
Everybody Dance Now like Billy Madison I
know this movie by heart yeah
horrible
will your mom named you after a bottled
water
all right enough Let's Dance
[Music]
thank you
all right lovers let's talk lunch and we
really cannot talk about 90s movies
without giving praise to Adam Sandler
[Music]
I think I know every single 90s Adam
Sandler movie by heart but my favorite
of all time is Billy Madison I can quote
this movie on demand do you want to see
nudie magazine day nudie magazine day
back to school back to school back to
school to prove to Dad I'm not hateful I
got my lunch packed up my shoes tied
tight I hope I don't get in a fight oh
back to school stop looking at me
Schwann if peeing your pants is cool
consider me Miles Davis
stay as long as you can you gotta
cherish it you gotta cherish it
to to today junior the mucus Queen is
yours
thanks okay let's get into that's enough
that's enough
we gotta get into the food and that
means one of my favorite Billy Madison
scenes of all time you know I made an
extra sloppy for you
I know
I like him sloppy
yeah all right well let's
go
I'm gonna make this plant-based because
I figure why not it's a really easy swap
to make even though I'm pretty sure when
I had sloppy joes growing up as a kid it
was literally just ground beef and
Manwich sauce which is delicious but I
also think we can bump up the nutrition
a little bit here so I'm gonna use some
plant-based kind of faux ground beef and
while I got chop in some veg here ABS
can you compare and contrast regular
beef with the vegan variety oh God I am
getting traumatic flashbacks to like my
grade six essay on The Giver like holy
memory unlocked but anyway since beyond
meat and impossible meat hit the shelves
in the mid 2010s there's been an ongoing
argument as to what is healthier faux
meat or the real deal and to answer that
question you'd kind of have to ask what
does healthy even mean but for a quick
comparison here's some food for thought
if we compare the impossible Burger
product Beyond Burger and 80 20 ground
beef we see that the faux meat has less
calories less fat less saturated trans
fat and more micronutrients and fiber
they have pretty much the same amount of
protein impossible Burger has a bit of a
nutritional Edge over Beyond if iron is
concerned for you because much of its
iron is in the highly bioavailable heme
form also found in regular beef the
downside of the faux beef is that of
course they are higher in sodium and
other additives which may or may not be
a priority or concern for you another
big consideration is the environmental
impact we know that beef production is
one of the greatest contributors to
greenhouse gas emissions about a
whopping 60 percent while plant-based
Foods contribute about half that amount
ultimately as you know I'm not vegan but
I basically only eat red meat if it's
served to me so I am super grateful that
we have some other options on the market
today that said these faux meats are
highly processed so I encourage people
to enjoy them in my moderation alongside
other less processed plant-based foods
and this is why I use this little hack
anytime I'm using faux beef I stretch it
out with some kind of Whole Foods like
lentils or in this case mushrooms so
bear with me I've got some cremini
mushrooms here I'm just going to pop
into my food processor
lid on
and we're going to pulse until they get
to like a ground meat like texture
because otherwise it's going to turn
into like a mushroom puree and nobody
wants that
step two add a little salt
and
get it in there and we're going to
squeeze out as much liquid as we can we
want them extra sloppy but not wet
ah
[Applause]
this really could have been the workout
right here okay
set that aside and make some Joes
all right
vegan beef down so I'm going to add in
some onions bell peppers and a little
zucchini because I have them in the
fridge and why not add the extra fiber
[Music]
all right
dump our mushroom meat a little tomato
paste
there we go a little garlic
and let's give that
some time to cook down all right a
little bit of
simple tomato sauce slim HP
which is vegan did you know not just for
steaks my friends a little red wine
vinegar
and some maple syrup oh geez
it's gonna work out folks
now they're getting extra sloppy
[Music]
I made it extra sloppy for me get a hero
shot of that this feels fairly authentic
so let's recap here folks we've got lots
of protein and fat in our faux beef and
lots of fiber in all the veggies that I
added here plus some extra veggies on
the side it smells like my childhood
it is so good like
Manwich is not man enough because a
sandwich is a sandwich but a manwich is
a meal
you're scaring this lady
one two three
oh
no
do I have to throw this toaster out now
it's gonna be a pickle in there forever
oh
I'm just gonna leave it there all right
lovers let's talk dinner and for this I
say we eat like an eight-year-old kid
living his dream in a massive house
without his Parentals
a lovely cheese pizza just for me
foreign
Nostalgia food I mean we always have
pizza on like a Friday night and at
every birthday party obviously so it's
just associated with fun okay but this
is controversial but when I was a kid I
didn't even want my pizza plain with
just cheese I wanted no cheese but it
had to be baked with the cheese so that
it kind of got the essence of cheese and
then I like to take the cheese off so
that it was basically just thick dough
with like a little bit of a soggy
tomatoey crust but that was it it was
just bread basically just bread and
Pizza Hut was the best kind of pizza
bread argue with me in the comments like
do you guys remember the Pizza Hut
buffet
I mean the ice cream bar at the end
there that gave me life but anyways
Pizza is just so easy to make so I
figured we're gonna do our own here and
that way I can add whatever the hell I
want okay stretch this out much as we
can here
a little tomato sauce
pizza night is so much fun I love the
idea of just like adding whatever
toppings you'd like and I remember
having like pizza parties as a kid for
like birthdays and you know every kid
got to add their own toppings
those are good times all right done I'm
gonna dry off some roasted red pepper
here
all right
I've got some sauteed onions and
mushrooms
so good
I've got some leftover chicken here that
I'm going to add for some protein
got some olives for some healthy fats
lots of Chase
to basically safe get to my younger self
who for some reason took off the best
part and this is my little adult twist
I'm just gonna Spritz the edges here
foot stays
some olive oil or avocado oil and then
I've got some everything but the bagel
spice
and you put that on the crust
trust me folks you will never eat pizza
any other way after you do this
let's Baker off
one eternity later this is unreal folks
oh
yes
hello
oh she's perfect
she's hot
you go to 94 Scissors because I'm all
about the scissors and I just make a big
old mess
pop it down the center
gotta get an authentic triangle
situation oh
hot hot hot hot hot hot hot hot hot hot
hot hot hot hot hot hot okay last
essential step
you'll never eat pizza any other way
let's recap we have
deliciousness all around I got carbs in
our pizza crust healthy fats in our
olives plus our cheese protein in our
chicken and I added some extra veg onto
our pizza and a little side salad as
well I already know that I'm going to
burn the roof of my mouth with this
cheese just like I did in the good old
days at Pizza Hut it wouldn't be
authentic without a nice bubbling burnt
soft palate let's try it I'm really
selling it aren't I
oh my God and it's so
so good okay so we cannot do a nostalgic
day of eating without a little dessert
and maybe reliving some childhood trauma
because nothing instills fear in me
greater than the thought of being thrown
into the choking
or like chucked over a fence by my
pigtails
[Music]
the childhood trauma I don't think any
of us will ever forget our dear Bruce
[Music]
okay so I chose this scene because to
this day I'm 35 years old and I don't
think I've ever seen such a moist
looking chocolate cake did I offend you
I hope I did like I'm not even huge on
chocolate desserts but that looks
freaking amazing but I also chose scene
because I think it serves as good
evidence of how early kids are taught in
their lives to equate fatness with
complete and utter disgust gluttony and
Punishment nothing about that scene was
dignified I'm fairly certain that it was
originally written as like a cautionary
tale to kids to like avoid eating bad
foods or getting fat even though in the
end Brucie kind of turned it around and
was revered for like sticking it to the
Man
a woman I guess in the case of
mistrenchable but yeah ultimate
ultimately guess that Brucie does better
than one of the other major enormously
fat roll doll characters of this disc
Loop because we all know how that one
ended up
the point though isn't it
this is stomach that's done that
side note Roald Dahl is recently in the
news because a lot of his texts are
being re-edited with more modern kind of
PC language and I'm not sure how I feel
about that but I will say that this
movie made me scared to eat chocolate
cake so what are we gonna do today we're
gonna eat the damn cake and I'm gonna
show you one of my favorite ways to
hunger crush and come out up
just toasting some nuts here folks
oh
what
I just bought this kind of Frozen and
thought I'd make myself
a molten lava chocolate cake
still good still good still good now
full disclosure
straight up chocolate
Little Greek yogurt
oh look at that
um
oh yeah lots of berries
foreign
toasted almonds for some healthy fats
and Abby while I work on this can you
explain why on Earth we would add
anything to a perfectly good molten lava
cake lesson some days I'm with you the
cake oh natural is all that will
ultimately do but I've been practicing
intuitive eating for over 12 years now
and in that time I've collected a lot of
data on what feels good to my body at 35
I know that I just do not feel great and
I eat a lot of straight up sugar before
bed especially a lot of rich chocolate I
often don't sleep well because I wake up
from a blood sugar crash in the night
and then I feel ravenous and a little
bit nauseous when I wake up and because
I have IBS I find my whole bathroom
routine gets totally thrown off and I
end up feeling bloated constipated and
generally cranky as the next day
but I still like to end my day with
something sweet so I have learned that
by dressing up my naked carbs with
protein fiber and fat I feel physically
satiated and emotionally satisfied and
not every dessert will look like this
but this is what I found holistically
feels best to me focusing on an additive
approach to Gentle nutrition like my
Hunger crushing combo helps support
healthy blood sugars energy levels
satiety and appetite regulation and
helps naturally Edge out some of the
less nutritious ingredients while
keeping you out of scarcity mentality
it's kind of a win-win-win situation in
my books Amen to that and on that note
how much fun was this day we got waffles
sloppy joes pizza and Cake it doesn't
get better than that folks but to my 90s
kids what iconic food scenes are these
did I miss also should we do a 2000s
movie list let me know in the comments
below what you want to see and on that
note that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]